everybody welcome to stream Coco Oh God
look at the claps we're very excited
zombie unicorn with us say hello Natalie
all right Beth of course over here in
the chat and creeper in the corner Jason
O'Malley under stress today by the way
under duress that's actually we're
playing rocket League with y'all up in
this piece so add Blair if you haven't
already and then we'll get you into some
games finally cystic ashy coab or is it
Cobb nobody knows sorry it's my fault
Gingras good to see you no it's not it's
my fault
because I had to get my red shoes all
right are you ready not terrible at this
um I'm actually really bad I'm literally
trash you know I don't literally trash
not figuratively all right we're gonna
go to create a private match shall we
can you do this [ __ ] where you're like
up in the air you know I I should know
how to do that but I've already
forgotten
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ] alright can you invite me ball
star 5 to 9 are you ball star 5 to 9 or
are you somebody else that's the
question don't let any password what did
we I think it's just Coco Coco is what
we did last time no BOTS 4 guys here the
settings so find us it's just the game
the name is Coco you can find us let's
do it great match it's happening it's
happening do I clean Natalie or zombie
you call me now or corny corny were you
corny oh there's a trash can there we go
literal trash oh the bad my name on most
like you good when you can make a
username I always call myself literal
trash that way when everyone's trying to
talk [ __ ] to me I'm just like yeah what
did you expect okay you don't you're one
step ahead of them
okay I see Gingras on the old blue team
I think I'm on the left and Natalie I'm
on the right I'm gonna go blue I'm gonna
go clear I'll go against you Oh blue
shigera so no color did you pick in
Pokemon go
curious I picked I would yellow with
purple hair because I did you pick a
team cut like a team yet Li know I've
been Tunde I'm only on level three is
that what am I oh yeah I think you have
to do it at level five I'm at the point
where I have to start doing that but I
haven't done it yet what's the deal with
the team so you could battle they're
just like an ingress really battle is
like sitting you're playing rocket Lisa
talk about Pokemon go yeah man it's the
best we can't scream pokemon go quite
yet so although we'll figure out a way
we should actually do a stream Coco on
the street yeah let's do that at
comic-con we're going to Comic Con by
the way next week we're very excited are
you gonna be down there yeah I'm gonna
be there how many years in a row have
you gone this is my first year going to
San Diego come what of really yes I'm
how long we've been in California for a
few years now yeah a few years that
you've missed every those Comic Cons
well Cody yep that's right looks like
someone picked the wrong team blues my
favorite color it's the color of losers
you know what [ __ ] ready that's right
who's gonna be the color of your face
that's good it was intimidating just cuz
it was so lackadaisical you're like you
don't even care about like you don't
even care about [ __ ] on me you know
what I'm saying there's kind of like I
think you're like I'm bad at this game
and then all of a sudden you're I
haven't scored a single point it's just
Cody Cody for news and fair Cody for
noob is on points
Cody Ferdie faker he's a hustler he's a
hustler he's a rocket League shark we're
just chilling first level fighter you
know we are you know what it is somebody
needs to Jill ugly chilly that's true
you know what really everyone is all
about the tricks but no one's about the
defense what's that movie now follow me
on this one what's the movie with oh
there you go well done part-time Pro
looks like she moved to full time thank
you
celebration Shady
now what do you normally stream on your
channel what are you into right I'm a
variety I do I am a variety it's a spice
of life man that's what they say I play
a lot of everything I I do a lot of
overwatch lately I haven't played
Mirror's Edge oh good what's the deal
with Mirror's Edge have you played the
original no I played a little game okay
and there's like time involved there's
time trials on some of them but some of
its not like time travel though no it's
just really satisfying parkour like it's
super fun
I can't do any of that in real life so I
would enjoy that highly really nice I
like to do what I call free walking
which is this me kind of like being free
and walking around it's like parkour jr.
you know like I'll be like jump off yeah
really jump off a curb no I gently step
off I want to hurt myself I'm not very
flexible kick my water under the couch
that's going perfect oh good nice nice
tricks yep nice moves yes get it I like
to think that my car is like farting
lavender smelling so you know it's like
I can pick all this Oh demonic no you
a-holes yeah Patrick John Paul quran'
has a question what is your question my
question for you is why do you have four
names pick one you don't have one is
fine Patrick Paul Oh somebody's loving
the stream look Beth what skylight books
great shirt yeah great shirt
nobody said anything about my New York
Times shirt today yeah I see and never
like what's the joke and I'm like
there's I don't think there's a joke
about the New York Times there's no joke
it's just a New York Times man it does
look like it should mean something
though doesn't it yeah I mean it's just
fancy it's just so fancy it's like Old
English typing ye olde Engrish the old
Engrish exactly come on I can't like
touch the balls how many don't be gross
how many shows we do at comic-con we're
doing how many beth four or five or four
shows but they'll all be spooked
so it'll kind of be like age shows I
guess we're doing a lot of stream poker
down there that'll be fun five last year
we had who who came by Bob's Burgers the
old will Myers from the Padres yes oh
that was great it was great just he was
just handsome you just had a couple of
gamer next door gals the play man the
best hand was like in freakin Hawaii
right now I said I was freaking and else
came by and jumped right over boys a
curry Levi came by and Oh Tyler Posey
Lord digger o31 I like to take credit
for others work so my team is doing
fantastic great job guys
you know what it's okay it's okay blue
team we got this I challenge you to read
kakari my name mini gamer I don't
understand you make sense damn it well
my result is in the home run derby
tonight oh yeah
well he can't ya see I think will Myers
came by with his brother because he had
like broken his wrist he was like out of
commission and they were like hey play
this game were you use your wrists
what's Gouda you're like I don't know
who knows what are you doing together oh
you know what it was it was a bump ball
Camden the ball can do you like to have
the ball track or do you like to go free
ball you free ball in I like to free
ball it of course that is the only way
to do it that is the only way damn it
come on lavender farts let's go as much
as I like to be like oh you know what
I'm really a PC master-race kind of girl
this even on PC you have to play with
the controller so I have no excuse oh
yeah you're like a big PC gamer right
yes yes yes what do you think of the old
ye olde
oh there we go yes oh it's so sweet so
the red shoes
oh these are best cos when I spill wine
on them you can't tell isn't a great
word vodka cranberry you can't tell papi
you're getting it's like Deadpool when I
kick people to death oh wow that was
really here we go quite embarrassing
what might take people to does statement
are your actions my actions
Jake scored Jake way to get like a
handle it just says Jake it's an Arabic
name says mini gamer well how did I do
I don't need to know it's Arabic I need
to know how I did with it
yo what up Luke look guys blue machine
is your penguin show us the ball cam
Luke you should totally draw everyone
here on the couch today
yeah these amazing drawings drawings is
that true super characteristic that's
awesome wait so wait how did you get
into streaming give us the back ear
trading card give us the history of
jumping off of curbs great Segway and
literally from ten minutes ago
I literally fell into I yeah you
literally fell into it I was a I was in
college okay I think journalism and I
work on the computer all the time for my
newspaper as we all do New York Times go
on and I stepped off a curb and rolled
my ankle so badly I couldn't walk for
like six seven months really that's
really good job orange team you sure
wasn't broken six or seven detached oh
yes awful it was not good
painful no but yeah so I spent a lot of
more time on computer and I started
playing games and then I really liked
this one game called smite and if you
play that no what is that it's a MOBA
it's like a third person MOBA so think
like League of Legends okay more like
you're looking kind of behind the
character over there I'm learning a
story what's the story of smite it's
actually all the characters are
different gods from different Pantheon's
so grateful Egyptians they got Jesus in
there Jesus they don't touch the Hebrew
Lord and Savior Jesus Christ
Abraham Yahweh no Yahweh don't do that
it would piss off too many bees ha ha ha
I just love ya game called smite rich
Jesus like people turning Bob love it
turning the water in people's bodies to
wine you just die you drink them it's
delicious
all right let's go again or do you want
to change you want to change teams how
are you feeling I'm gonna stick with
blue blue blue so you got into smite and
you started doing it yeah and then I I
wanted to get better so I watched other
people streamer whoa and I played with
them and then they encouraged me to
stream and then that's kind of just how
it took off that's awesome
and and that's a the rest is history are
you going auto wait oh no no oh oh I
can't do orange I gotta go blue I can't
do blue what oh you dicks I'm spectating
oh I hate I hate everywhere where are
you in I don't think I am either you
guys what the [ __ ] yeah Blair thank you
we can't we're all gay believe it yeah
we're out of this match - you guys got
two eager guys got too eager this is
what happens we're punishing you for
your enthusiasm
I'm still at robber vets are still
laughing about thinking Beth showing
that kid a vulture what did you oh yeah
you dialed up symbol okay that's a best
good at creating horror we're doing it
again guys we're in we're hat's
happening you know what now let's make
it a little bit the same because I guess
it's only fun for I thought it was gonna
be like 8:00 on eight alright now we're
back in no box no box that's great and
now you're doing you're streaming it up
do I see you want some eleague stuff
somewhere sometime no did you do any
kind of eleague thing guess not that's
crazy
I'm like I've done so many things now
that I'm losing track but I don't think
life is a nightmare and gaming which was
a show oh that's what I'm thinking yeah
yeah it's not like a real tournament
it's more of like a don't don't say that
it's a real tournament you want to join
uh oh wait oh we didn't even get you in
this now we got to get out here it's not
a real tournament
what is it it's more for its at
personalities like YouTube personalities
head-to-head bunch of goof around but to
make them ups a bunch of you I think I
got will the laugh on that one proud to
make a box over there
hit hit a old options button hit the old
there we go there it is already start is
we're not finding a match though we're
creating a private match
I say yes no day were you from I grew up
in the Dallas area alright I got snow
down there no okay not really with every
four years so this is this is great this
is good from this I'm from Michigan so
this favors me okay yeah its snow day
your so much is like sleet's everyone's
freaking out just like when it rains
here in LA yeah exactly the same when
it's like mildly humid people like wig
out I'm going orange again sorry
slippery I've actually never played on
this kind of map neither vibe we're
about to find out
let me in let me in there we go see you
guys are back in the match what's the
deal captive quasar what are you talking
about
no one knows wow I got oh it's a puck oh
I love it
that's awesome guys dough it is slippery
is more slippery he did sure there's
footage of it rocket league is like Hot
Wheels meets soccer it's awesome yeah
it's the best
and also the worst for the environment
just cars spitting out smoke driving
around exploding in mini putting midair
it get out of there get out of there
I'm so bad I could have easily done that
rich [ __ ] why is hockey a puck by the
way why is it a ball it slides butter on
the ice I think the unwieldy a ball of
you and wheels bounce everywhere what
more unwieldy than playing on ice what
are you talking about I mean but like
don't they have like floor hockey
friends I got this
hockey puck two guys who's the hockey
experts in the chair like floor hockey's
probably like a football somebody look
at Wikipedia tell me about hockey I'm
curious
I like knowledge you guys this is
primarily an educational what if they
and so this thing bounces like a mofo
and it's the worst what if the only
leader of garbage trash what if they did
this isn't I thought what if they did
like hardcore like super strongman
hockey and they did it with like one of
those curling things oh my god game on
could take forever one have you ever
played broomball oh no but I've seen it
three balls great Oh see that I am a
gosh I love it on you you're allowed me
to blood on these shoes you are Wayne
gosh oh that was a great I am gosh
everybody hoops I'm rocket League no I
have not
I don't watch hockey no that's you can't
I'm sorry hockey it's all about fights
it's not about fights dude it's not all
about fights there we go
it's like our NASCAR is all about
crashes it's not but people that's why
people watching hockey ball would sound
weird coming out Don Rickles mouth a lot
of things sound weird and terrible Kelly
I know Don Rickles mouth I'm getting so
try-hard right now okay so what trihard
so trihard I'm like getting up this is
what happens when I try really hard to
get me get really quietly squish my face
a lot making like raisin face you got
trihard raisin face the worst here we go
kidnap kidnapped the first record
organized game boys how to use a wooden
puck to read for leaving the rink ah cuz
it doesn't fly up as much that makes
sense about so I wasn't wrong with the
bouncing we're not wrong you're exactly
right
rubber pucks were first made by slicing
a rubber ball and then trimming the
discs
[ __ ] that knowledge snaps in my face
yeah we're saying is I shouldn't have
invested in that hockey ball company
that was a bad investment
I did actually invest weirdly I was how
did he could to get into stocks this is
now like oh like its iconic like Warren
Buffett like I read up a lot Warren
Buffett like always you know he's made
gajillions of dollars by like coca-cola
and like his whole thing is investing in
companies he likes right and like that's
how Shaq has made a ton of money to like
Shaq owns like 50 fat burgers basically
and so I was I got like what do I like I
was like oh I like wiffle ball yeah it's
like I would invested with a wiffle ball
company so I invested in this company
called it was like zazen Matassa point
or like ZipZap or is that believe zeebee
out is that buddy duly incorporated and
[Laughter]
part of the game and oh god I just yes
I'm a gosh you're a so literally ara
gosh and I you know I invested like a
hundred dollars lost it immediately like
in a week they went bankrupt
there's nobody plays a wiffle ball guys
play more wiffle ball make my stock yeah
yeah but just pick just balls such a
dick invest involves man I bet no one
plays pro wiffle ball guys but let's
start it nobody played pro hockey till
somebody started it I know it's a bad
example but they don't absolutely it's
like hot no it's not high lies like
wiffle balls
we're expensive except for way more
dangerous yeah yeah yeah people should
we stream some real high line at
comic-con oops
yeah why do people point at that seems
ridiculously hard I lie
what's the deal you just got a thing and
you do like this a lot go team blue we
got a big it's like lacrosse but like
one of your hands is a basket is that
the idea about like what is that it's
like a see almost like a c-shape right
so that's sling and what's the point of
Heil I like points just pull oh here we
go here we go oh that was a great blah I
was a great save dragonballs I'm working
on it I'm working on it I'm working on
it play defense play defense I said
defense so much coming till that's put
the ball came on see I don't always play
the ball can't [ __ ]
[ __ ] I'm a gosh you carried that
team tactician did you know they're like
he's guys did great
I'm like the cheerleader I'm like the
ball boy oh man
somebody told naps but that ball came on
put the black him on hey was toggling it
I decided to stick with it off but I'll
I'll take your advice and go back to it
are we gonna let's change the match
settings here the snow ain't doing it Oh
hoops
oops there it is that's I've actually
never played this now it's on what's
mutator settings like gravity and stuff
do you think so I bet you it is I [ __ ]
you idiot each I might oh my god
yeah ball wait yeah it's like ball
bouncing it what do we do you want it
wanted it what do we want to gravity
super high gravity oh that would be hard
I would say if anything low that might
be fun
this is gonna be an oh wait no all right
uh uh did we get it or not I might not
have got it in time sorry buddy how many
hours do I have in rocket Lisa's
Slytherin
[Laughter]
point seven five hours maybe I don't
play a ton of rocket League rats
streaming how many hours you have not
very many I'm not a huge rocket leader
not only not not an RL er no what are
you do this again we did it again we
gotta get on that so YC years later that
match all right
psych gotcha more bounce please all
right strontium Doug will get you the
fajita brothers but the UFC for two
million dollars and sold it for four
billion I should start with a fighting
organization hey guys but what about
like mean words the fagina brothers
always been saying for heed I guess is
vagina Cuban setting me straight there
you go I do want to open a place called
the armed PETA a PETA store don't steal
that idea Internet I think it's already
it's already copper it's stolen
it's been it's beds done been stole 30
Beth we need to see you play - super J
cult fan super jackal fan have you seen
that clueless gamer we did with Jay Cole
everybody calls him Cole because his
boss is Jay feel Jay Z you can't have
TJ's you know man Blade try out among
the sleep you'll like it is a short game
all right I played that one it's a
little horde me now we didn't get you in
there
listen we're gonna put it together and
it's gonna be beautiful
you've played along to sleep yeah you
play as a baby around you see the world
oh I mean I'm a baby inside so that
works I'm an emotional baby
I could probably match hip sure oh
you're in I mean you did your thing I
play a lot of horror games and among the
sleep is technically a horror game you
gotta play inside it's so good don't
don't read anything about it yes
first-person shooters yes those are my
those are my favorite genre yes and
you're in - oh but you're just joining
us Abba unicorn follow our twitch TV
slash zombie unicorn with noe and
zombies because I'm a [ __ ] it don't
say that don't put yourself down
youtube.com slash done zombie unicorn
with knowing zombie instagram.com slash
those out everything else is the zombie
unicorn with no
perfect get in here getting this get in
the game dude thank you
oh it's just one-on-one oh alright this
is gonna be a show I think other people
can join though can't they do we have to
get know cuz it's low gravity
yeah but can other people not join guys
come on get in here nobody knows we're
gonna get this put this guy can I try to
be our gaming yes have you tried vr
gaming yes what do you think where you
tried to vie for the vivre I've tried
oculus and we've I think the HTC vive is
freaking awesome
can't wait to get one myself crazy town
and I have been fully immersed I have
seen a friend of mine do it with like
the haptic gloves and I'm just like whoa
wait what's that
um the gloves that have like sensors
that like can make you feel holy crap
cuz we did it with the two remotes yeah
awesome yeah that's crazy
wow that's crazy how does it like a spot
where you put the remote it's like it's
not like out out yet you know it's like
somebody's working on it God have you
read that book ready player one oh yeah
of course
well you know how it's like the full
body haptic suit and all that like yes
we're so moving toward that it's crazy
absolutely guys how do you get in this
game you can't joints this hero penguin
why not did I screw up guys I screw up
guys guys hey guys did I screw up I
don't know which is better which is
which I don't know which VR thing is
better right now I'm not sure there is a
oh wow good job hey first-timer I think
we found your game says the server is
full oh did we do 1v1 I don't I don't
believe we did leave it again third
time's the charm
the four ties it's the last was you
really did you don't want to go up
against me I can tell now I'm pretty
sure all right let's see here okay guys
listen here we go four all right check
me out here for out for hoops the old
did too did dunk house right everyone
we're gonna try to get in this you ready
John NY I show 12 if you don't have the
game it's gonna be really hard for you
to play with us you have to change the
name because there's already ah got it
thank you got it yes we created a match
for somebody else to see I will say PC
master-race you have a keyboard which is
better than this situation which how do
we this is I think on other games I
always prefer you should put the e on
the end that way there's my e from my
name there we go it's the lofty
alright now it looks like this here's
the game guys Co Co Co e Co Co Co E
hey Reese what's up yourself just
joining us for the zombie unicorn today
there's an awesome streamer so how do
you wait how would you describe yourself
um I usually say twitch streamer
youtuber vlogger host voice actor so and
that's the short version along
everything I say social influencer there
we go because that's what it really is
right that's what it is man social
influencer is happy to you join yes boo
per drop get in here get on in boobs
alright boys joint you got to join up
join up yes I did it come here
oh girl here we go how do we pour drop
how do you join you find the match we
made which is Coco with then you get the
end and then you join and then you watch
me do nothing and my team destroy yeah
we got low gravity now this is this is
what you wanted this is what you wanted
love it this is so funny oh this is
actually how I Drive on the 405
a lot of fun would be a lot nicer if
there was no gravity it would be hell
that is it people can't draw people have
problems driving with gravity
Jojo F the password is Coco with no II
rocket League is love rocket League is
life a feeling a sign silent night 11:7
Robert veg we should play some Castle
Crashers sometime we should play some
castle crashers
maybe we play after this and we put put
a pin in this battle block theater oh
you know what we have bad luck food
around here we play that that's a good
game after this match why don't we
switch over there yes please get Conan
Conan is coming to work a little late
today we had a big crazy secret shoot on
Friday night if you followed us a
snapchat Team Coco you saw some behind
the scenes of that amazing stupid
ridiculous fun shoot uh yeah we're
getting some stuff ready for a Comic Con
shows it could be very fun this game
really worth the money reach it totally
is worth the money I think it's worth
yes because it's not that expensive
expensive
that's like 85 dollars American sorry
it's cheap 85 pesos actually that's
right it's good this game is really fun
to play with friends you get really
salty but would you like playdough if I
start eating me sweaty is that we're
talking about Oh knows I'm sweating
profusely yet you just get like good
[ __ ] talking yes I should talk like
twitch twitch users will know pjsalt in
the chat baby pjsalt emote oh boy I need
to get we need to get our email game
going the emote tip what it could say
emote slang yeah it was free once about
a time you're right jungle-gym mania but
then wasn't everything he would jump by
his son Lillian turkey who's that woman
ill this is zombie unicorn she's our
guest today
say hi chat I mean will type it
we get insulted assaulted yeah tingles
I'm not doing high fives by the way
anymore
it's too violent and this world is
enough violence okay
an aggression so now I'm dude I'm just
doing a little tingle that's what it is
you know it's nice yeah it's it's bring
some happiness in the world right guys
there you go there's some internet
singles for you I don't want to touch
the lingo hey I don't want to know I
feel like it would be hey guys hey guys
how do you how do you spell like this
[Laughter]
how do you spell because that's what I
normally do when I do tangles also I'm
crazy and I meant have you stroke no way
Coco I love this hasha hasha been seven
eight six Conan I was very sleepy we had
a shoot from 6:00 p.m. to 6:00 a.m. and
they brought us a taco truck a coffee
truck which by the way the coffee truck
left at 10:00 p.m.
what we're they're just 6:00 a.m. what
are you doing coffee truck oh sorry
taking off at 10:00 p.m. that's not fair
and then they had a breakfast burrito
truck which is great it was pretty dope
like you were nervous about it I'd this
low gravity it's UV on the server name
is Coco with an e at the end and the
password is Coco with no E as I tried to
make it as confusing as possible there
we go coffee truck regulating my sleep
yeah no kidding I had to go diet coke I
felt awful by the end of the night or by
the dawn whatever it was if there are
any subs of mine in the chat can you
guys throw down some zombie G's zombie G
oh you got your own you got your own
jams I have yeah I have emotes you got
some emotes now emo
does the emo it have the hair passed oh
yeah does the hair stay the same or does
it change it stays the same I've had
for four years and then Peter natural
you're like - yeah I dye my roots in my
eyebrows brown okay makes sense I might
I had gray hair when I was 14 oh so it's
I am a freak by Nature
that's what it is man I it's like the
shittiest ex-mayor
I have like a great patch in the front
from wherever birthmark whoa pink so
nobody knows there we go well no and why
the picket blue you know does it mean
something is it like world peace is it
just the cheapest two colors at CVS what
are we doing coolest looking colors it
is equal it's [ __ ] neon 80s retro
[Music]
it's the best yes no TV it's also great
because if you commit a murder then you
can just dye your hair brown no one will
recognize you
your reverse-engineering the perfect
crime I've actually put on a wig and it
looks like whoa totally different really
yeah that's because how long have you
done it for years
whoa it's like weird to see me with
normal colored hair now yeah I can
imagine that's awesome I love it
I should have dyed my hair pink for the
stream I should have actually if I had
my druthers about me Beth great work if
I had my druthers about me I would have
gotten some sort of a wig or something
you know I would have gotten a gray wig
you're my house you know I have like
yeah when I was I actually left for a
month to to go do something and a friend
of mine would stream in my you were in
prison you could say you're in prison
the law cut up he put on the wig now and
started streaming on my channel for me
[Laughter]
trying to do my voice and everything is
great which are hot by the way like
they're very warm you just start
sweating eg an itchy it was like a cheap
plastic one for sure it's like real hair
yeah it's a hat made out of hair I mean
what are we doing oh there we go
on your head are these yours what is
this you yeah those are mine those are
yours all right there we go
jo Bob's you know for when there's
always someone in the chat always asking
for boobs oh come on guys upstairs here
I got a little something upstairs
just don't let the New York Times fool
you I'm not very well-read I just
yelling oh this uh can I join I'm a PC
or do I need plan pubes for I don't know
actually I'm sorry I don't know if it's
cross-platform I've never questioned oh
if we get a hashtag druthers go and I
guys I'll be so happy
I'll show I'll show my Bob's it'll
happen let's see Gingras please John
Gingras is like Karen let's see your
Bob's that mess right there that's all
of my emotes oh that's awesome
I think you mean that beautiful art
gallery
you got the trash the great one that's
me
which one this really yeah you notice
whatever air Pepe yeah yeah I cost
I didn't stream once where I cosplayed
and I did the makeup to look like that's
really fun how often you stream not
often enough anymore but I you stream
like every day that's amazing does it
break you down emotionally because it
would break me down emotionally I would
do it how do you how long would you stay
a lot of times it's like chill streams I
would sometimes dream for like 12 hours
a day though is that metric or is that
English that's crazy
I don't 24-hour charity streams - that's
a meet and so how do you you say of
course we try to sleep a lot beforehand
and then you drink a lot of caffeine
maybe you do usually do like like
donation goals for charity so like get
up a new jumping-jack get in get in you
know a hot pepper get in I'm gonna be on
your Jimdo Thank You Aaron the same team
yeah I saw that I am a gosh totally
switch team yeah traitor
that's crazy writer what's what's do you
have any like what are some of your
favorite streams you've ever done or
like they've been a part of like high
low it's always like the 24 hour streams
just because things just get nuts yeah I
think the last 24 hour stream I did I
you have an arrows have you ever heard
the game keep talking and nobody
explodes oh sure we played yeah then
played that with who came in here and
played out of this Oh feel Vaughn yes
that fun game right great game I did it
where I was defusing the bomb and right
right after it ate a hot pepper and I
wasn't allowed drink the milk until I
diffused it it was it was me but the
devil it came from a show called on
YouTube called hot pepper gaming where
they do the reviews you and I did one of
those and that was really fun that's
awesome we had we played we'd like Paul
Scheer and Rob Huebel in here and also
the cast of teachers came in and we
played somebody sent me these jelly bean
have you seen these jelly bellies that
Bertie Botts right well half of them are
gross yeah we're good it's that Harry
Potter ones well no no no they're
they're they're going off of that idea
there it's this game called bean boozled
bean boozled yeah yeah and yeah so we
played and if you lost in Mario Kart you
had to eat and literally like people
were spitting up into the trash piece
not they were so [ __ ] gross like the
spoiled milk one I almost lost it oh
yeah no you rose I haven't done that
I've tried a couple of them but I
haven't like done the challenge or
anything but I've done a soda challenge
where you have like I call it pop pop oh
yeah there you go
a pop some pop so conversation like
yesterday of course you northerners yeah
northerners are the best the best of
course it's the best but you did the
soda pop challenge yeah it's like a
ranch flavored soda I think that's just
ranch like teriyaki flavored soda
like really weird spaces like it was
actually not bad it was pretty rancid
because that charity is kind of sweet
yeah okay you don't it tastes like to me
it tasted like eggs with syrup
okay not a terrible I mean it's a
terrible I wouldn't choose it I've had
it and I do the waffles and I just mash
everything together just not the same
place yeah all goes the same place sweet
though yeah they used to have vaguely
that we used to have celery soda which
is weird because you don't think celery
has a taste and then I was like oh my
god this is exactly celery like it's
super weird and I had some really cool
name like I don't remember itself
something yeah Avon 5l and one I'm
reading the chat and by the way get a
better name bro what are you doing I you
know those are like all the letters I
can't get rid of in Scrabble what do you
bow to kick I am a gosh oh my gosh when
I doing another close game with Conan
very soon very soon
that's what eyes should show this dream
show this shape it's this we're doing a
plug Lucroy by the way or clockwise
it's like SAR think we're trying it's
sponsored by liquor because we let me
drink a disgusting amount of stuff in
this office so it tastes like shitty
water that was the original name [ __ ]
water and then it turned to sell sell
sell right that's what it is
Stella Raye which is like terrible
Avenger
hey guys it's celery
what if celery is really good at
Microsoft Excel I know all the functions
in the songs celery actually celery
would be pretty like a villain
the old cellar a cellar I wouldn't need
to be a superhero sorrow is good at
Excel they just make a ton of money cuz
no one knows how to use Excel hi oh my
gosh is neelima playing you're right
tayo Silva I'm playing I'm just so bad I
like to wait till the very end and then
just also do nothing I just need to
uninstall my facebook exactly that's
that's cross-network I don't know nerd
classic how would you cross network John
Williams 30 yeah I do sound like a Conan
nerd after you work here for a while
everybody just acts like Conan that's
exactly what it is it's uh kind of
horrifying you just have your and I Jude
you're on Game Informer from a couple
months back by the way hey thanks other
night that was very nice than to
interview me that was cool and I did it
in a hot car while my mom was in a
thrift store okay so it was a quick
interview I'm not even trying to figure
out what's up Matthew North I'm gonna
try to figure out how they do that
flying you see that well are they doing
dude I think they just point up and then
hit the fart button the fart button yeah
whatever the fart book is it should be
austere part it should be Oh have I ever
touched Conan's hair have I I have cut
touch Conan's hair it burns oh god it
burns
[Music]
we've had an old people moment rent
overdue I am old so all my moments are
old people moments well there be any
movie cast guests on Coney comic-con
shows you know I can't talk about that
I think we're booking all presidential
authors actually yeah oh is it yeah it
is I don't even know who no joke I don't
even know if he's on the ships that's
why I was playing dumb because I am dumb
and I wasn't playing
oh yeah
gotcha Jared Leto's Leto's I'm super
stoked for the new Harley Quinn oh man
oh there you go nice are you a big
Halloween er I am I was gonna say I'm
big I'm a big Halloween er
did you guys last year I last year I
cosplayed as uh as the Suicide Squad
Harlequin there we go
and made it on stream and everything do
you girl yeah you do does she have
tattoo did you like do that I wrote the
tattoos on soon very funny
nice yeah I don't I see you a lot of
cool ink I am too scared to get a tattoo
you oh there goes the meals and also
here's my thing all right I'm just gonna
say it
I think it's easy to get a tattoo yeah
you just get it once and it's on you
forever
it takes if you truly love something you
truly love so we follow me on this
follow me on this follow me on this you
truly love something you take a sharpie
no right you can write even write on
yourself every day that's commitment you
know this is like oh I did it once you
know I you know I have these boobs on my
arm and so sometimes when I'm filming
and you can't have boobs in the shot
they have to draw little gaff tape right
there just a little bit we're like a
sweatband it's very fashionable that
could be guys maybe that's our
million-dollar idea we come up with
clothes for tattoos
yeah there you go they don't forgot yeah
exactly and you just put on and then it
looks like she's wearing like a little
yeah you know a halter top and you could
she could have like a hula skirt
oh yeah it's awesome seconds remaining
to lose
okay blue me team we're wait we're on
the same team s team are you talking
[ __ ] I'm on my do Garvey is doing your
time what color your eyes dead I'm dead
inside
my eyes look at this think of a shark
going in for the kill
that's what I said the winner of this
all a minor walls it's terrible it's
absolutely terrible should we actually
play a little bit we got 20 minutes left
tree after this play a little bit of
what we're saying battle about theater
ladder ladder black bladder box theater
that actually would be a great game
bladder blues my friend and I had this
plan this prank we're gonna pull we're
gonna put on diapers and go to see like
a really serious movie and then halfway
through go to the bathroom and see how
many people would stay and then we
realized we just have to sit in their
own filth for how this is a terrible
idea
alright good job orange well done Oh
shocker I'm a guy seven shots on goal
way to go well done zing time dot
bwahahaha amber waves of game by the way
I love that name amber ways of game well
done very patriotic all right let's try
for the old bye bye bye good webcam for
streaming's much taxi 920 is a pretty
much standard oh my god are we talking
shop now see what it was seen at the
c920 90% of streamers have it is that
the long one okay there we go
see I know my stuff kind of wait what
are we playing I'm losing my oh my god
I'll go Dez we could try to play Octodad
if you want I think it's single player
it's double flare oh you've never played
two-player I've never won person does
happy arms I love it's I hate it because
it's so frustrating
played it Oh download
[Music]
how was it gonna take to download to try
sure that's gonna screw us up a mouse
all right let's try it
I played this back when it was on a
laptop several years ago pause for
bragging pause pause her hipster go on
go I go and she played it when it was on
a laptop well it was um the guy was just
showing it at this indie game thing for
a fan tact have you ever heard of
Fantastic Fest no there's so many fast
put a word but fest after it it's a
sci-fi horror movie festival sounds like
a blurred fest at the Alamo Drafthouse
awesome oh god I love the elbow drop yes
but I've never been like oh my god how
many like no this is actually like a
really cool one but they have like a
gaming part too and it was on of course
this was on it cuz it was like weird and
awesome we don't have it on this on this
PlayStation God what about Angry Birds
Star Wars no you know what now it's on
oh I love Star Wars but I really don't
like ink well too late now we're playing
it that's what it's like what's the
movie oh it's Ghostbusters we ever
supposed to clear their mind but then
this is your Stay Puft Marshmallow Man I
am into the new Ghostbusters by the way
I can't wait to see it written by former
Conan intern Katie Dippold
I was like I'm gonna go see it and it's
not out some next week it's out so next
week a lot of heightened a lot of hype
YouTube chats the worst well I don't
know sometimes I think you to be pretty
good today what do you get but you guys
are on your best behavior for old zombie
unicorn here thank you very much
where can people see you again twitch
out TV slash zombie unicorn everything
else is done with no Wiens on no Ian
zombie if you just google it you'll
because she's cubish doctor she's a
[ __ ] alright here we go
we're in okay I don't care about that
now
now they didn't want to play so now
we're gonna play and we're playing
multiplayer and we're playing let's do
it can I be
can we play online no local only two
player it is so I'm a huge it's like I'm
sitting next to generally yes he hummed
all that did you know that that was
actually his voice yeah it's like your
sticker oh my god why can't I be drunk
beer I'm gonna be this furball laugh it
up fuzzball Catholic quasar zombie no
Ian zombie unicorn you gotta you gotta
like unlock these I'm guessing I think
so I think so definitely shot first you
can see we play this a lot here we go
yes I'm a big guy no I'm a big nerd for
a Darth Vader I collect some help in his
helmets really yeah have I got a whole
shelf Oh cuz they do this pop pop
culture yeah pop ones and then like I
they had like Easter eggs that had jelly
beans in them and they're all Darth
Vader schools so I haven't one oh that's
awesome
piggy bank one and damn I've got them
all sizes and shapes what is your what
is the crown jewel of the Darth Vader
collection I have
we're gonna get dis amazing okay
embarrassed embarrassed how do I feel
your pillow there you go
that's him that's awesome how big is it
oh that's dope
what if his head was really that size
baseball I suppose he retiring [ __ ]
yeah it's perfect for this right now Oh
money
yeah yeah oh yeah yeah oh do it get it
done
am I supposed to kill all those guys
possible take your first shot I will
shot I will shoot the first oh I see you
have to press like there we go Wow first
time catching a streaming thanks crazy
pac-man appreciate it okay pop quiz you
see the thing in the bottom the the P at
it what some people say 80 18 it drives
me alright I know what are the
communists that's terrible I love a TST
but it's a tad are we doing no no it's
oh it cuz the 80s t yeah because he's
saying s terrible ah take my second shot
here we go oh it was I don't know what's
happening oh it's nice it shows you the
path alright so I'm supposed to kill all
these dudes right I think you have to
kill them all tell them all she says
hashtag kill them all die rebels calm I
feel like I should go straight in right
straight forward do it I gotta hit that
Tina T alright let's see yeah I'm going
straight
oh yeah nice I killed that 88 I saw it
on here you guys have played the Star
Wars Battlefront we have it's good but
you still made it oh I was hoping you
hit the TNT the twister we four went
before went can you say four-way we've
we've four gone for gone I don't have my
druthers about we stop playing rocket
League an hour playing they're playing
whatever this is it's still my turn
no that was my turn I press what see we
alternate here's the thing we what now
it's why does it let me shoot the button
or did you press I just did at the same
time you I was some time gonna do this
every week yes shin van hare warden come
by come by a cream you say the letters
separate well Rob revenge I'm sorry I
also say ASAP so I don't know what you
want me to do invite Jordan we did
invite three long time we need to fight
a begin its we invite him again you
really like I start would you be playing
Star Wars I don't remember no we didn't
we played some it wave item why does
well there's a girl here it'll probably
show up I mean you're a girl - Beth I'm
sorry yes sir cook your coworker so yes
there's rules yep
have you seen Jordan anything that
Jordan does on our show he's the
associate producer and a psychopath
impossible murder he loves Star Wars and
Harrison Ford smashed his Lego
Millennium Falcon it was great yeah wait
for the clip it was a great thing for us
Jordan was very upset someone is
actually saying that a they were they
were saying you have to say it out like
yeah I'm not gonna I'm not going to do
that so no Lucasfilm has gone on record
to say it's a dad thank you look it up
look at this one research
father see bothers me
fathers freaky that but they also said
it was Indiana Jonas which I don't
really agree with I'm not into that it
seems like he's the coolest Jones Jonas
in the weird the coolest Jonas brother
all right
is this this is not gonna do anything
but how do I get those dudes you go up
all right the window gotta count for a
win for that wind yep yep yep yep oh yes
about the bounce the bounce this is so
close that was a great shot self high
five well done Blair or so I knew self
tingles take a fourth shot and needs
more Jar Jar Tim otaku you're wrong this
is a new mat for rock yeah
you guys haven't up you guys gotta
update that yeah got it download the
update and update
oh it's too far we've gone too far no
those perfect that was perfect that was
great oh those go no that's what I
should have done well done well done
what's up guy well done Barry jealous
Glen Andreessen super rude to see you
here zombie oh hi it's not that weird
still the internet come on if you
invited Jordan be lucky to get any game
time in cos Jordan would spend it all
telling you the history of the game
especially with Star Wars he actually
doesn't know anything about video games
Jordan does nothing about Star Wars but
when it comes to video games his
knowledge is irrelevant right thank you
it's like is our game oh yeah no so it
is if you guys play the new team cocoa
get Kony to comic-con game
and you die which you will often and I'm
sorry about that you'll see Jordan the
last thing you see before Kappa soda HD
zombie you play like a girl that is a
compliment curtsy girls are dope exactly
exactly
JK lmao well alright fine I you know
what I do say lmao I don't Salem ow and
yeah three levels should we do three
levels we got 50 no are we gonna go we
go another game so we got three number
three game wait yes oh
octave dad's not done dammit it's almost
dead once he got in here can we could
play we could play some Battlefront
no disconcerted oh but the disc is right
here what do you want to play call it oh
what's this one to the right Magic
Circle that right oh boy yeah it's the
one that looks like Conan that we never
played you want to play that let's do it
I don't think I mean I think I don't
know what is this Oh home
oh we did play this game oh this game
bad choice well let's we beat it so
we're not gonna play it it's basically
the whole time and I'm sorry if you
don't want this to be spoiled close your
ears earmuffs the whole time we're like
is all the signs are pointing this guy
being a murderer right so we played the
whole thing it's like oh this guy's a
murderer and we're all thinking oh
there's gonna be a twist it's not
there's no twist he's just a murder yeah
we thought we were murder and then we
were murdered okay and then we're all
murders and I was like oh this is
horribly depressing let's make one more
match Iraq yup okay because it's with
the field fan aru's East Burt I feel
like if you killed someone you would not
just spend two weeks in prison unless
you escaped and that is Tim I fight have
you played prison architect no but it's
great I am really good at running
Judy game yeah it's like it's like
little Weeble wobbles younger those but
it's like Weeble wobbles look like
knives and the showers yeah I saw that I
saw the trailer for it Adam the game of
the true oh yeah
it was really cool I was uh I got a I
got a say I was very uh very into it
Prison architect also get inside what do
you do with your lives
that's so good
all right here it is it's Co Co II pass
where it is Coco we're not doin hoops
what do you wanna do you call it there's
only oh we could so car Mad Max you want
to keep it on do you like a look over
your net that's already bad enough as it
is restore defaults dem faults I like to
say restore damn fault yo alright let's
do it guys get in here do I have a ps4
community I don't know what that means
there in Westwood but I like your name
cuz it's my name and it's easy to
remember it's the best named Jack
sparkles play zombie please where do I
go for the Conan goes to Comic Con games
this Star Wars kid double O team
koco.com slash Comic Con join now get in
there I'm going blue do you want to
switch cuz you like blue okay notice me
Christie m'kay consider yourself
witnessed I was gonna say what a
glorious day that Conan game is easy in
on a second level we programmed it in
like two weeks
give us a break well if you keep dying
the Jordan quotes are all different yeah
so there you go so there there's some
good advice for you kids keep dying
that's what I like to inspire and I like
I what's the room name it's Co Co Co Co
EE
it's so weird going for the wrong color
now bleh gah okay greater
strontium dog 360 mediocre exactly
getting into the this I am into this by
the way this might be my favorite board
I've seen the map yeah I play plants vs.
zombies know if you play plants vs. I
have not that way
[Applause]
why are the plants and zombies fighting
each other like what's the story there
I don't get it what's the what's the
story what's the issue I feel like they
eat the plants and the plants are
fighting back no zombies like brains
they don't like well yeah but in this
world actually you wanna hear a joke
what what did the vegetarian zombie say
great tomorrow jokes from the fourth
grade bad jokes dad jokes hashtag dad
jokes blessed ounces captain Saudi
you're right that's correct
bless down for that one less sideways
we're playing a ps4 volley toss mom's
you dad stop blessing out my friends are
over the plants are defenses to your
house is Terran our eyes so it's kinda
like day of the Triffids or whatever
that's right
look it's actually a novella but that's
not gonna do since the girl with the
skylight books Chiron does even know a
classic [ __ ] think that's where there's
a it's where there's I'm gonna tell you
all the plot crazy this is by the way
like from the 50s it's a story where
there's a everybody in the future there
are these things called Triffids which
are plants that people mined from
petroleum and they're like they eat
people but they keep them all in pens
and then there's a meteor shower that
makes everybody blind and the plants get
out and they start killing people it's
very confident it's like super sized
super sci-fi hey huge fan I'm a huge fan
here is Joe Joe hand
yo y'all hi exactly mm-hmm captain
scented dad stop dabbing because I'm
sorry I'm always dabbing I was naturally
dabbing was a natural damn sneeze dab
sneezed at your shoulders polite it's
true is that how it started I would like
to think so
joke his cringe dude my life is cringe
so get used to it
hashtag cringe life damn I'll get in
there please don't please Luke Tang I'm
so sorry
looks like the vines are Jumanji yeah
okay obviously the vines are you talking
about the I think you're talking about
the ruins not the vines how do you like
horror movies norm yes yeah the ruins it
was crazy
that was it good that's it that's a fun
that's an oldie buddy well not that
oldie but old enough
yeah and a kitty you know one of my
favorite like horror sci-fi horror
sci-fi like name something like Keeping
Up with the Kardashians I always like
psychologically have you seen it follows
yes no it's scary to me as I was hoping
it would be okay it was pretty good
though I didn't know about anything when
I when I went in to see it I knew I
heard nothing so I was I loved it like
the John Carpenter each score was great
like it kind of shine Detroit which is
scary
reminds me of fallen do you remember
that oh yeah with Washington that's a
great one event horizon great movie
Pandorum okay there's a movie it's my
favorite one as far as like
psychological goes it's called the
corridor whoo what's that it's it's as
weird it's a Canadian movie also eating
from and it's this weird play they all
go camping out in this place all the
time
and there's this weird like area that
has like these supernatural powers and
it affects everybody differently and
then they all start to go crazy
oh nice taking off his own skin stuff
like that it's really I'm often wanted
to take my own skin off it's really hot
sometimes in LA you know what I don't
need this one less layer I say one less
layer oh that's cool that's awesome
stuff for the woods always freaks me out
anyway because that's a very cabin in
the woods tankmen yeah Kevin that's also
a good one also a good one what I just
saw really great you oh did you see 10
Cloverfield Lane because I I've been
love with you I've been playing video
games you know kind of Jesus guru no
porker best name I've heard today
well done poodle pork that is a great
goddamn name I'm gonna need my kids with
a work order it was so it was cool nice
hello oh the descents good descents
great yeah it's fun it's interesting
because like comedy and horror
they are like only one tick apart but
you know there's a lot of like porn
comedy horror and it's interesting
because I think they both really benefit
from low budgets like some of my
favorite movies are low-budget movies
because you know you can get like a
really cool idea up on the screen with
either comedy or horror because you know
it's like the interesting Kolchak that
Christine Kolchak the night stock or
that old TV show that x-files is based
on but it's like damn it that was a good
one that was lucky but a wait it's
really low budget but it's almost more
scary cuz I'd use like shadows and stuff
so it's actually there like helps that
they didn't have a lot of money to make
it it actually makes it way creepier
which is awesome
yeah man I'm a huge chance oh the thing
things my favorite horror movie carpet
is the thing man that remake though what
are we doing their lives there's this
amazing I don't really care for zombie
movies too much but Pontypool it was a
low blow
hey that's like this whole different way
that they get infected so it's like
interesting takes place mostly by
drinking sell race over call back what
is it how do they is it is it a secret
how they get infected
yeah don't tell me that I want to see ya
that's all because that's the whole
movies they're trying to figure out how
you get infected oh that's good what the
heck how's this whoa whoa whoa there it
is
back zombie voice that was crazy zombie
unicorn boys Kolchak with the dad me
Christmas story that's true captive
quasar the dad my Christmas story as a
journalist who tries to whoa that's a
shark that is a damn son well done oh my
god well guys that'll do it for today
thank you to zombie unicorn for showing
up follow her on Twitter on TV slash
zombie unicorn and the zombie unicorn no
II ends Abby everywhere else and make
sure you check us out next week we'll be
at Comic Con good god it's next week oh
good lord
good lord it's gonna be crazy thank you
all for joining us thanks for playing
rocket League I'm a gosh put in some
more work and you're not good enough
you're not good enough
you only scored 50 goals ah thanks a lot
for joining us stream Coco we'll see you
next week
you